jamie lynn spears is setting the record
straight
i am now ready to tell the story the 30
year old former nickelodeon star hit
back at
accusations she's getting paid by her
older sister britney spears
amid the pop star's 13 year long
conservatorship
posting this screenshot of a headline
reading britney spears's sister jamie
lynn shares photos of her home life
after it's revealed she is the only
family member not on
singer's payroll jamie lynn then added
quote
facts now leave my broke ass alone i
love her she's like she's 10 years older
than me but she's like so stubborn
and she's like so headstrong and she
makes me laugh she's
hilarious britney's money and who has
access to it has been a
hot topic of discussion lately the new
york times revealed
last month that britney's dad jamie
spears gets
sixteen thousand dollars plus two
thousand dollars for rent for an
office per month per the new yorker her
mom lin
and brother brian also get money from
the entertainer
in documents obtained by e.t last year
the stronger singer paid her attorneys
and team of advisors
over 1.2 million dollars in 2019
and that same year her dad received 128
000
as a conservator and while jamie lynn
claims she's
not on britney's payroll according to
court documents obtained by et
at the time she was named trustee of
britney's sjb revocable trust
last year which means the pop star's
younger sister will be responsible for
ensuring her fortune
is transferred into a trust benefiting
britney's children
in the event of her death i think it's a
very big deal that she's speaking out
and
she has told the court she wants her
voice heard
britney appeared remotely before a judge
on june 23
to address the court directly with an
explosive testimony
slamming her family and requesting to
terminate the 13 year long
conservatorship
without being evaluated this marked the
first time in years that britney spoke
in court about the conservatorship
which has been extended until september
2021.
this is a very important that she's
decided to speak out now and i think
she's doing it because
basically she's come to a head and she
needs to figure out
what she's going to do about this
conservatorship and she thinks
this is the best way to get her point
across
under the conservatorship the pop star
claims she has been forced to take birth
control
and says she's not allowed to ride in
her boyfriend sam askari's car
she also stated that she would like to
sue her family
i think it's extremely clear that's the
day i was born i've only loved adored
and supported my sister
i mean this is my freaking big sister
before any of this bull
after brittany's testimony jamie lynn
took to her instagram story saying that
she supports her sister
100 percent my sister knows i love and
support her
that's the only person i owe anything to
i'm not my family i'm my own person i'm
speaking for myself
i'm so proud of her for using her voice
i'm so proud of her for requesting new
counsel like i told her to do many years
ago
and she shut down those who criticized
her for not speaking out
sooner maybe i didn't support her the
way the public would like me to
with a hashtag on a public platform but
i can assure you that i've supported my
sister
long before there was a hashtag and i'll
support her long after and jamie lynn
says she supports her sister no matter
what
and just wants whatever makes britney
happiest
if ending the conservatorship if i'm to
mars or whatever the hell else
she wants to do to be happy
i support that 100
because i support my sister i love my
sister always have always will
as long as she's happy